[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNY DEARBORN: So just
a little bit of context.
For a long time, obviously,
we were subsistence farmers,
and then we've had several
industrial revolutions
over time.
We are now on the precipice
of the fourth Industrial
Revolution.
Pretty significant
impact on our workforce,
our global workforce.
What has been
consistent for each
of these industrial
revolutions for success
is human ingenuity,
human creativity,
and for us to create
opportunities.
And I am firmly a believer
and an optimistic for growth
mindset.
That we will always find
enough work for people to do.
It is our responsibility, coming
from the center of the universe
here, Silicon Valley,
that is our responsibility
to sort of lead that transition
for certainly the United
States, the global workforce,
into that new state where
work is very, very different.
One of the ways works is very
different is sort of grounded
in an internet of things, right?
The cyber physical system.
The coming together
of these two worlds.
Certainly I don't need
to tell you about this.
But this puts us in
technology in a good place
because we understand this,
we understand the impact
that this has on
jobs, and how IoT
is displacing a
lot of traditional,
sort of blue collar, high
school education type of jobs.
And that is creating a
pretty significant divide
and is really an
opportunity for us
to sort of step up, and
help bridge this gap,
and bring more people along.
Just a quick case study of tech.
So in this 25 year period,
we saw a real shift
in how sort of major
economic forces
happen in the United
States and in the world.
It's fantastic for
shareholders, but there's
a pretty significant
impact on workers.
So in this 25 years, about
the same amount of revenue
and about 10x less
number of employees.
So a really different
type of work
and a really different
type of worker.
So if you have an iPhone, you
can turn it over and it says--
remember what it says?
Manufactured,
designed in Couperin,
manufactured in China,
or something like that.
Or designed in California,
manufactured in China.
So it's a great example of
these two different economies.
Manufacturing economy
and the creative economy.
And the creative economy,
there's a lot more spoils.
There's a lot more
wealth that's generated,
but for a much fewer
number of people
and a really different
type of person.
And maybe that was OK for a
while when tech was smaller,
but as IoT gets into
everything that we do,
every device, every Roomba,
everything in the world
is going to have some
IoT system in it, that
cyber physical
system, there's going
to be this incredible demand
for engineering skills
and just not enough people
to meet that demand.
So this model won't
hold moving forward.
We won't be able to generate
this amount of revenue
and this amount of
market capitalization
with as few number of
people moving forward.
We'll need to expand this
number, this 137,000 employees.
Just for comparison, this
is, these two numbers,
1.2 million employees
and 37 million employees,
that is the entire
production supply chain.
So that's everybody
who's making a spark plug
and making tires
and assembling them.
Everything to the point of sale.
So this causes a
challenge for us.
We already know-- this
is not new information--
that 1% of the global population
controls 50% of global wealth
and 50% of the global
population has 1% of the wealth.
That's not new
information at all.
We know that rising
inequality, wealth disparity
is a significant problem.
But it affects all of
us because societies
that have the greatest
wealth disparity
also have the
greatest instability.
You can see here more violence,
more people in prison,
more obesity, lower
life expectancy,
lower trust in government
systems and institutions,
things like that.
Inequality is rising
in all countries, even
those that have
experienced rapid growth
and a drop in the
overall percentage
of people living in poverty.
So this is something--
again, the mission of your
tech company, my tech company
is make the world a better place
and improve people's lives.
We're in tech because
we have the power
to make the world a better
place, and we're super excited.
We're going to use our passion
and our energy to help society.
And so I feel a
tremendous responsibility,
a personal responsibility
to do what we can.
To really further that mission.
And I feel like I can do that
in my role as the head of talent
and learning at SAP, which
is a major tech company.
As we're looking at
projecting out the talent
needs for the future, the
next five, seven years,
I know how many
engineers I'm going
to need in which
countries, and I
know how many engineers
are coming online,
and there's not enough.
And I know the
staffing needs for most
of the other companies in the
world, major sort of players,
and there's not enough people.
So there's a tremendous
concern that we need to do more
to sort of help fill that gap.
We know that there's a lot of
very exciting technology coming
online and great opportunities
with that technology.
But there's also a
lot of disruption.
Again, I'm very optimistic that
we can work our way through it,
but I feel like we need to
do more to smooth that out
as we look at the impact
that technology has.
So driver is the highest
self-identified job
in the United States.
So this includes not just 18
wheeler drivers, long haul
trucks, this includes taxi
drivers, Ubers, school bus
drivers, city transit
drivers, private limousines.
So driver is the highest
self-identified job.
And there's an opportunity
here as this technology
comes online to think
about retraining
and to think about what is
the education that is best
for these types of workers.
And one of the things that
I think about in my role
is, what is that cutoff point?
What is the tipping
point when you
can take talent and transition
them to something new?
And when is the
point where you say,
this particular type
of talent is best
to learn not programming skills,
but entrepreneurial skills?
Because they're going to
need to do a little bit more
pulling themselves up and
figuring something out
because we as a
society may not be
able to create
enough jobs for them.
So how can we help
these different folks?
A quick story.
My mother, when I
was a little kid--
I grew up in the '70s
in Sacramento Valley.
And she was a bookkeeper
at a local travel agency.
And the local travel
agency was in the mall.
Davis Time for Travel.
And all the moms worked there
and that was back in the day.
If anybody can remember, we
had to make an appointment
to get a paper ticket to go
from San Francisco to Frankfurt,
and that was what
travel agents did.
So certainly a huge change
in the travel industry.
Companies like Expedia,
and Travelocity,
and Priceline, and
things like that.
So the travel industry
saw a huge increase,
but travel agents, we
saw a huge decline.
About a 40% decline
from the peak in 2000
to today of that type of job.
So people who were
travel agents,
those jobs were all
over the United States
in every little
mall here and there.
And they were great
middle class jobs.
High school education jobs.
And now the industry
is doing great,
but a really
different type of job
in a really different location.
So no longer spread out all
over the country equally.
Sort of concentrated
in tech hubs
in different types of companies.
So my mom did fine.
She was a bookkeeper
and she just
went and became a bookkeeper
at another little business
in town.
But not everybody sort
of has that resilience
depending on the type of
skills that they have.
And what is our responsibility
to sort of think about and plan
for the job changes that are
happening across the country?
So this study was, it's a
2013 Oxford University study
and it was praised
when it came out
for being both incredibly
visionary and very criticized
as alarmist.
So it's probably
something in between
as we look at the different
jobs that are likely to go away.
And we see the same pattern
for every sort of wave
of Industrial Revolution.
The jobs that are most
likely to be eliminated
are the ones that are the
highest in physical skills
and the lowest in cognition.
So there's also other
research that 83%
of people who are earning $20
an hour or less, their jobs
are likely to be
eliminated in the next five
years due to automation.
The jobs that are least
likely to be eliminated
or the most safe are
the ones that have
a high amount of human skills.
What is uniquely human?
What can't be automated?
What can't be outsourced?
What can't go online?
And things that have a high
amount of human manipulation,
creativity, social
perception, things like that.
We'll see a very
significant increase
in psychologists,
human resources, people
that are helping others
cope with change.
Do you have a thought?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JENNY DEARBORN: There you go.
Job security.
So you could probably tell
just by reading the news
that we are at the lowest levels
of unemployment in a while,
but the highest
levels of anxiety.
So we can sense that.
People are doing well, but
maybe underemployed and nervous.
So our economy-- and if we look
across a host of industries--
is really badly
in need of workers
skilled in computer science.
There are half a million
jobs going unfilled now,
and in a few years it's
estimated that nearly a third
of all computer science related
jobs will be left unfilled.
We graduate in the United States
about 43,000 computer science
graduates a year.
And a tenth of all
new jobs are ones
that haven't yet been created.
So we're looking for
people for occupations that
haven't yet even been designed.
So another study that if you
started a four year computer
science degree today,
by the time you graduate
in four years from now
your freshmen content
is no longer valid.
So incredible rate of change.
And really, the best thing
that we can do for people
is help them focus on
fundamental human skills.
Resilience, creativity,
innovation, social perception,
cross-cultural awareness.
You know, these are really
what is significantly human
and can't be at risk of
automation and outsourcing.
So some other stats
that should worry us.
We're not in good
shape globally.
These are the 34
market economies
that make up the Organization
for Economic Cooperation
and Development.
And you can see that,
for example, Japan always
comes out in the
worst spot in this
because they're a significantly
high aging population.
And also the increased
life expectancy
is making it a challenge
in a lot of countries.
As we try to transition
to something that is new,
people are less
comfortable as they
get older transitioning
to something
that is really, really new.
If you're born today
in North America,
there's a 50% chance
of living to 105.
If you're born today
in Japan, there's
a 50% chance of living to 110.
So how do we think
about preparing
the future workforce when
our careers will be 50,
60 years long?
And, you know, what
is the education
that you need to give you
that foundation of resilience
and fundamental human skills
to be prepared for a very, very
long duration of change.
So this is 16 to 65 year
olds, but what about our kids?
Fundamentally, I'm an educator.
So given what we know about
the future of technology
and how essential computer
skills are to our economy,
it seems pretty logical that
understanding the algorithms
and applications
on the internet is
going to be essential
for our kids'
health, their economic
abilities to sustain themselves
in the workforce.
And it's probably,
moving forward,
just as important as
understanding photosynthesis,
and the digestive system,
and, you know, electricity.
So we need to really engage
with our school systems
to understand how we can create
the workforce of the future.
Similarly, what I
talked about before,
that there's sort of this
threshold of when you can teach
people things that are
brand new and then when
it's time for them to learn
entrepreneurial skills
to create something
new on their own.
Because of the talent needs
that are coming online
across all these countries
and all of our companies,
we can see a very significant
demand for certain skills
and not enough
graduates coming online
across all of our countries
that can meet that demand.
So we have to dig deep
across all of our companies
and dig into the K
through 12 system
to make sure that it's preparing
the workforce of the future 10,
20, 30 years out.
So what's a super bummer--
now we're going to
get into this stuff.
It's all just a huge bummer.
So 90% of parents want their
kids to learn computer science,
but only 40% of schools
across the country teach it.
And what's awesome is that
kids that take computer science
really enjoy it.
Schools that have computer
science and engineering,
the kids are excited about that.
So parents want them to learn
it, kids want to learn it.
Tech companies,
all companies are
desperate for these
graduates to have it.
We don't have enough
graduates now,
but I'm not thinking
about today.
I'm thinking about
10, 20 years out.
So that's why I'm focusing
on this population
to get them ready.
And we see a very significant
disconnect in the coming years.
This is not new information.
Everybody knows that a lifetime
earning of a college graduate
is significantly higher
than a high school graduate.
20x is your lifetime earnings
as a college graduate.
But also as a computer
science graduate,
it's 40% higher than the average
of all other degrees combined.
And so computing jobs
are the number one source
of wage growth in the United
States in every industry,
in every state, and
they're projected
to grow at twice the rate
of all other jobs combined.
Again, there's only 43,000
computer science grads
that come online a year
in the United States.
So states that invest in
computer science education
really reap the economic
benefit as well.
It's not just at a personal
level, it's at a state level.
So there's only 10 states, and
California isn't one of them,
that have K through 12 computer
science education standards.
In 2017, those 10 states
were 9% more likely
than states without K through
12 computer science standards
to see unemployment fall.
So this was original--
so in the US, I think we all
sort of know this intuitively,
that governments and
corporations change
at a really different rate.
So this chart shows the
rate of change of technology
is the blue run here, and
then the rate of change
of public policy in
alignment to that.
So what I am really
challenged to do
and would love to put out
the challenge to others too,
is to see what we can do
to sort of close this gap.
This change gap.
Can we look at other sources
of computer science education
to get more people
engaged in this solution?
I am also a firm
believer that perhaps we
can do more in
our HR departments
and our hiring to meet
people halfway or meet people
a little closer
to where they are.
This is just a quick snapshot
of Silicon Valley's community
college system.
So some basic facts about the
California community colleges.
2.1 million students are
enrolled in California
community colleges.
They are the nation's
largest institution
of higher education.
114 schools.
They are, across California,
67% ethnically diverse
and 53% female.
30% of all 16 to 24 year olds
in the state of California
are enrolled in a California
community college.
30% of every kid 16 to 24.
So that's across the state.
But here in Silicon
Valley, we have
17 colleges, 263,000 students,
and 70,000 of them are in STEM.
They are 71% diverse
here in Silicon Valley.
But what's super
cool, I think, is
that 30% of the
grads from all UCs
are California community
college transfers.
And 51% of the grads of all
CSUs are California Community
College transfers.
48% of all STEM graduates
from all UC schools,
UCLA, UC Berkeley, are
California community college
transfers.
Almost 50% of every
engineer that graduates
started in a California
community college school.
So as we look to broadening
our pool of people
that we're recruiting from
and helping more people sort
of move forward, I'd
like to challenge us
all in tech to think about
where we're recruiting from
and who we're looking
for as we pull people
into the workforce
of the future.
So there are a ton of benefits
to California community college
school kids.
I should also say that it's
really tough to transfer.
Only 4% of the kids
that are enrolled.
So 4% of the 2.1 million
students transfer
to a four year school.
It's really hard.
And so you get somebody
who's been through the system
and come out, then you know
that person is pretty resilient,
and smart, and determined.
And so those are also
great characteristics
to be looking for as we look
to the future of the talent.
And let me also
tell you a reason
why I am super bullish
about this system
is I'm a product of it.
So I have a confession to make.
This is why I'm super
motivated about this.
So I kind of, like, barely
graduated high school,
and went to the local
community college.
I grew up in
Sacramento Valley, so I
went to American River
College in Sacramento.
And it was there
that I was diagnosed
as dyslexic, and attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder,
and obsessive
compulsive disorder,
which my high school
didn't recognize.
They just thought I
couldn't sit still.
Everyday I got wiggly
and they would just
send me out to run the track.
And so I was super athlete but
I really didn't learn a lot.
And so they figured this
out at the community college
and they gave me the
resources that we need.
So I went from sort of
D's to A's, transferred
to UC Berkeley on an
academic scholarship,
and then a master's at Stanford
on an academic scholarship.
So what does this have to do
with the internet of things
and the automation of jobs
in the future of workforce?
It's really about opening our
eyes to an alternative path
and opening our
minds to what needs
to happen if we're going
to have a strong economy
and a just society.
If we're trying to
make a difference
about wealth disparity
and a stable society,
it's about inclusion.
It's including all
sorts of people
from all kinds of
backgrounds in that future
because there's going to
be a lot of disruption
of a certain type of person and
we could do a lot more in tech
to include those people.
I heard the term tech lash
for the first time in--
I read, I was
reading The Economist
maybe three weeks ago.
And it said there's a tech lash
coming against Silicon Valley
by Washington.
And I heard that
for the first time
and I was physically shaking.
So I think we could do more.
I mean, I'm a Silicon
Valley person.
I said, you know,
Berkeley, Stanford.
I'm, like, here.
This is my world.
And we could do
more to help people
in other parts of the
country to participate
in the future of work, because
we're going to need everybody.
So you guys are doing a
tremendous amount already.
So I'm not here to preach
to you and tell you
that you should do
something different
because you are absolutely a
role model in reaching out.
You have a tremendous
volunteer culture.
I was doing some
research about you
and you have this
great partnership
with Goodwill,
which I did not know
is the largest
workforce development
nonprofit in the country.
And you've pledged $10 million
dollars and 1,000 Google
volunteers to
create opportunities
for 1.2 million youth, formerly
incarcerated and displaced
workers, and veterans to
give them digital skills
to participate in the future of
work at the 156 Goodwill stores
across the country.
So that's fantastic.
That's fantastic.
So certainly applaud
these efforts.
But there's so many more things
that we as a tech community
and we who are
all sitting pretty
with our great degrees,
and our wonderful jobs,
and our great future,
there's a lot more that we
can do to bring a more
inclusive view into the talent
that we need.
So it's really about being open
minded to all kinds of talent
and all kinds of backgrounds.
Look for those
scrappy people that
had to pull themselves up
and do something the hard way
because maybe they've got some
cool skills that we could all
benefit from.
Encourage students of all ages.
It's never too late
to learn something new
and to dig deep and try
and do something different.
And then my strongest
call to action
is really around lobbying
for K-12 computer science
education.
And even if you
don't have kids, this
is about doing what's right for
the community and the future
of work because we all want
to live in a just society
and in a place that sort of
closes that wealth divide
so that we can have a
safer and more harmonious
environment to live in.
So there are interesting
things that can be done.
It's not just around
volunteering at a school.
But people who are
working in schools,
they know that they have
a significant challenge.
It's not just going to a
school and saying, well,
why don't you just put through
computer science standards?
They know that they should.
Why don't you just hire
computer science teachers?
They know that they should.
They cannot recruit computer
science teachers at the rate
at which school
districts can pay.
If you have those
skills, you're going
to go to a place like, you
know, your company, or mine,
or a lot of others.
So what can we do to
sponsor a teacher?
Pay for a teaching role?
You know, maybe five
engineers get together
and they all work a four ten
schedule and everybody rotates
and actually teaches a class.
There are things that we can do.
You can adopt a school.
You can adopt, you know, just
like a chaired professorship
at a university, you know,
sponsor the computer science
department at a school.
Things like that.
So there's a lot that can
be done to get creative.
I've been talking with different
people at the national level
around creating social
sabbatical programs
for employees, tech
employees, to go and volunteer
for three months in a
government organization.
There's more that we can do
to make our presence felt.
And this is not just good for
schools, it's good for us.
So this is a quote from a Google
employee about how this really
changed his life.
So I found this quote
on the code.org site.
So I was super excited to
see a colleague of yours who
was making such a great impact.
And I want to leave you
with some links of things
that you can go and check
out about ways to help.
So thoughts, questions,
feedback, ideas, reactions,
anything?
HR people?
Marketing people?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
elementary school education
and then the community
college scene,
but I also keep hearing
that applying to schools
is getting so
challenging and kids have
a lot of anxiety around it.
So is it also that
we have to increase
the number of four
year programs,
or is it really
earlier than that?
JENNY DEARBORN: It's
earlier than that.
I mean, there is stress and
anxiety in all these levels,
and a lot that we
could do to make people
feel that a lot of different
paths are worthy, right?
I mean, I have four kids, so
what I keep telling, you know,
when I go talk to
schools, there's
a lot of second chances
in this country.
You're going to
have a long career.
work for 50 years.
There is nobody saying
in their right mind
that you have to do
XYZ in four years.
Explore, take risks,
learn new things.
Go to culinary school.
Change your mind.
Do this for 10 years.
Go get another degree.
Do something else
for five years.
Get a different degree.
Stack a bunch of
micro credentials.
There's lots of different ways
to get to a really satisfying,
joyful life.
There's not one path.
So it kind of goes
back to your point.
I'm trying to encourage
HR peers to back off
a little bit from it
must be this university,
it must be this degree.
Because I think there's
enough research and data now
that says there's not
a direct correlation
between this university and this
degree with high productivity
and high success.
You can get there in
lots of different ways.
And sometimes the
circuitous path
is what creates a really
interesting colleague
and a really
innovative perspective.
So my advice and
encouragement to schools
is to back off on the
stress and encourage
concepts of lifelong
learning and joy
and internal motivation for
a long journey of learning
and discovery.
Because if we don't
have that from within,
we're going to be stuck.
You know, we maybe have a great
degree that last for 20 years,
but what about the next 30
that you are still working?
AUDIENCE: You touched on it
a little bit as you talked
about the statistics
around community
colleges in California,
but I'm wondering
if you have any research or
thoughts on as we're working
to kind of reskill or skill
the future in computer science
and tech, what about
the intersectionality
of making sure that there's
still that diverse workforce
coming up with that?
I know that's a hot
topic right now.
You know, do you have a
diverse workforce in tech?
And we're seeing that
there's gaps in gender
or different ethnic groups.
So have you done any
research into how
you can skill the future
for these needed gaps,
but also ensure that
you're bringing up
a more representative
sample of workers as well?
JENNY DEARBORN: Yeah.
Well, I mean, that's why I
talked about the diversity
in the California
community college system.
You know, it's 53%
female and 71% non-white.
So these are great opportunities
to find diverse talent,
and that's incredibly important.
I mean, as we think about
the role of technology
in our lives moving forward,
when you sort of project out,
you know, internet of
things and how technology
is in everything, do
you want the people who
are making technology
decisions to have
a really consistent sort
of frame of reference
or do you want--
I want the people who are making
technology decisions to have
a very broad background.
The often quoted
example I didn't make up
was about self-driving cars.
That if a self-driving car
has an unavoidable collision
and there's a driver in the
car and the self-driving car
notices that there's four
pedestrians on the sidewalk
or whatever and a collision
is absolutely unavoidable,
does the car make
the decision to save
the driver who
bought the car, one,
or save the pedestrians, four?
What is the right
decision for society?
What's the right decision
for the person who said,
well, I bought the car.
You choose me.
That's my car.
Or I don't know.
I mean, you know, so that's an
often quoted example of, well,
who's making that decision?
The car.
OK, well, who
programmed the car?
Who hired that
programmer of that car?
What do all of the
cars consistently--
what decision would
all those cars make?
Is that the right decision?
What is right in that situation?
What is just?
I personally would like to have
a lot of diversity in the room
when the engineers are having
a conversation about what
that car should do
in that circumstance.
So I think it's imperative
that we have diversity
in the new forms of technology
moving forward so that we have
a greater representative
viewpoint in these really
interesting, sort of
ethical conversations
that need to happen.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: So there's
a lot of companies
now with massive online classes.
JENNY DEARBORN: Yeah.
Sure.
AUDIENCE:
[INTERPOSING VOICES] so there
must be a lot of students
passing through that.
And it's a question
for you and probably
some people in the audience--
are those students successful?
Have they learned?
Can they use those skills in
a business workplace today?
JENNY DEARBORN: Yeah.
Well, I might get this
a little bit wrong,
but it's pretty close.
I think 80% of the people
that are taking [INAUDIBLE]
already have
undergraduate degrees.
There's about a 5% completion
rate for people who
start classes to complete them.
And the number one class on
Coursera is how to learn.
So it kind of goes back to,
what is the most important thing
for us to know?
It's how to learn.
You need to learn to learn.
You need to learn to unlearn.
You need to learn to relearn.
You need to prepare yourself
for a 50, 60 year career
because we're all living to 105.
You know, of constant change.
You know, retiring
early might be 70.
So how do we get ourselves
in a mental space
as a society of constant
learning and constant change,
and being OK with that
and having that not
be an anxiety
producing experience,
but a joyful experience,
a great opportunity?
So yeah.
There's a lot of people that
are experiencing those classes
and they're great.
We do them at our company.
You do them at yours.
And so it's interesting.
I mean, I think that we should
be backing off on the pressure
to have the best degree
from the best school
and all that, and be
more open and accepting
to diverse paths like
stackable micro credentials.
That's great.
You know, there's lots of ways.
Going to a code school,
going to a coding boot camp.
There's lots of ways to get
really practical experience
that is more open to
diverse backgrounds.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
JENNY DEARBORN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So in today's
world, the big tech
companies, do you think--
suppose a student, like a
community college student
did complete a Coursera course.
Do you think that they're given
due consideration by the hiring
team or do you
think there's still
kind of an elitism
towards prestigious--
JENNY DEARBORN: Yeah,
there's still elitism.
AUDIENCE: --universities.
And what can companies like
Google and NASP do to fix that?
JENNY DEARBORN: Yeah.
There's still a safety
to choosing someone
that has a four year degree.
My perspective is
that you should be
able to prove your experience.
So whether you have a fancy
degree from a four year school
or you have a bunch of stackable
micro certificates on top
of a community college
associate's degree, either way,
you need to prove to me
what you know, right?
As a hiring manager.
What can you do?
So in a more of a portfolio
approach to the hiring
process where we're
talking about actual work,
tell me about a time when
you actually did something.
Show me an example.
It's a great, easy
shortcut to say
what school did you
go to because we all
know the vetting process that
goes through for those things.
But as the demand for workers
increases and certain roles,
we will need to expand our
acceptance of alternate paths
to education for
those particular roles
because the
university system just
can't produce them
and bring them online
as fast as they're needed
across all of our industries.
So what we can
do-- your question
is what can we specifically do.
We can step back and
have a conversation
as an executive team around,
what are we actually trying
to accomplish?
What is our strategy?
What are our goals?
Can we achieve these
goals by having
a broader perspective to
talent and how that talent sort
of came up in the system?
So I think it really starts by
us as companies sort of looking
deep into ourselves and saying,
what are we actually trying
to accomplish here and
what are the different ways
that we can accomplish
those goals?
Yeah.
Cool.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: I haven't seen
any information on this,
but one way I would
imagine we could increase
the incoming pool of talent is
for large companies like Google
and others to put money
behind some of these schools.
Not for the reliance to be
solely on the government
to support these schools.
But I've not seen, or maybe
they're just done quietly.
But there was a
time when I expected
that there would be Google U.
JENNY DEARBORN: Yeah
AUDIENCE: And it was a
brick and mortar school
that you could matriculate
into from any high school.
And it met all the
standards, et cetera,
but the money came from within.
Is that being thought
about or done in any way?
I'm just not aware of it.
JENNY DEARBORN: I
don't know any plans
about Google U.
That's not anything
I would have awareness of.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Google
opened Howard West University
[INAUDIBLE].
That's what I was wondering.
Yes.
I know some companies
that have MBA programs
that the company pays for,
but they're full programs.
And that's where I
could see that we
could expand our capacity.
JENNY DEARBORN: Yeah.
Well, so many companies do this.
SAP does also.
We sponsor five different high
schools across North America.
That's a partnership between
the company, a high school,
and a local community college.
So it's a six year high school.
At the end of six years, you
graduate with a high school
diploma, an associate's
degree in computer science,
and practical hands
on experience.
So it's like an
apprenticeship program.
It's a very close collaboration.
We have one in Oakland,
there's one in New York,
there's one in Canada.
So yeah.
Other companies do that too.
It's a great sort of first step
to making a huge difference.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you.
This is very relevant
and eye opening.
So you mentioned earlier
in your talk skills
for children to have.
I don't know if that was
children or all people in terms
of this learning path.
You mentioned resilience,
cross-cultural awareness,
creativity.
What were the other sort of
essential things to learn?
JENNY DEARBORN: Sure.
Fundamental human skills.
So creativity, innovation,
social perception.
The World Economic Forum
has a list of 16 of them.
I can send you the
list and the link.
Emotional intelligence,
empathy, creativity, listening,
active listening skills,
leadership skills.
You know, you have fundamental
numeracy, fundamental writing,
fundamental communication.
But if you look at
the list of 16 skills
from the World Economic
Forum, what really jumps out
is how many are in human
to human perception.
Yeah.
That's what's really
distinctive, and different,
and exciting to see.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank
you, Miss Dearborn.
Thank you everyone for coming.
Let's give one more
round of applause.